now please welcome your hosts megan
mullally and nick offerman
[Music]
hello
hey welcome to the 37th annual
independent spirit awards
where we honor the best of films and tv
shows that begin with the a24 logo
that's right
what an amazing year for independent
films yeah after two years of covid
audiences are finally returning to the
cinema
movies are back
wait
no
no no no don't don't applaud they're
they're not going to see your movies
okay
they're going to see the eighth
spider-man for the sixth time
i saw red rockets six times
six times
you watched it three more times without
me
maybe
what is going on with you and simon rex
do you love him
there are things about him that i love
just
a big penis
oh
oh god oh god okay
what's up what's up honey uh
maggie gyllenhaal and peter sarsgaard
are here oh
the motherfucking gyllensars
all right all right everybody i'm sorry
let me explain um
nick and i were kind of hoping that we
would be the biggest hollywood power
couple in the room tonight you know for
once
but uh
i see someone invited them
come on
indie stars and a-listers pick a lane
you greedy bastards
why do they have to be so great
all right wait a minute wait a minute
wait a minute let's think about this
nick you know what maybe we're
overreacting
maggie let's start with you i mean sure
you're one of the most acclaimed actors
and directors in hollywood but um
you ever been on a sitcom
huh
ever hosted a short-lived daytime talk
show
no
i didn't think so
sarsgaard
you ever done a recurring role on a
george lopez multicam
or anything on abc
we rest our case
okay i feel better
oh man
isn't it so great to watch these movies
on the big screen and by big screen i of
course mean the iphone 13 pro max that's
right yeah that thing is huge it barely
fits in my hand huh barely fits in my
hand
what's up honey where'd you go oh i
don't know for some reason i just
started thinking about that movie red
rocket again huh
what a film god damn it
is this about simon rex again and what
his piercing blue eyes
guys
you lost me you know what i think we
have a clip roll the clip no no we don't
have a clip oh okay great well i have it
on my phone
yeah
oh man can that guy run wow honey snap
out of it get your put yourself pull
yourself together i'm really sorry i'm
terribly sorry okay back to the show
hey this is huge pick another word i
can't
four out of five of the best directors
nominated tonight are women and don't
yep
let's hear it
and don't they look pretty hello ladies
way to go biatches
for real
what no no nick i mean this is kind of
remarkable there's only one guy
nominated mike mills for come on come on
what
only one guy
this is an outrage we can't let him get
away with this everybody get out your
phones right now and tweet at the spirit
awards hashtag topple the matriarchy
now this is bullshit i think you're
missing the point all right pressing on
all right
akira nominated for best feature
that's right
is a movie so italian that the subtitles
are just a series of hand gestures
let's um let's see some of the hand
gestures sure
all right okay
oh
okay
yeah it doesn't seem particularly
italian but
maybe i just haven't been to italy it's
very good yeah
another movie that's nominated for best
feature tonight is zola
zola is written and directed by the
amazingly talented genixa bravo
so to you miss bravo i believe it is
only fitting to say
good job
drive my car is nominated for best
international film
it's a tale of shame loss and infidelity
between a director a writer and an actor
in japanese theater drive my car shows
that no matter what language you speak
theater people are a lot
and in the spirit of fairness we counter
balance
honoring the films that no one saw by
also celebrating the television shows no
one has ever heard of
i don't want to brag but we watch a lot
of tv at our house that's right
we really liked philly d.a
which is uh up for best non-scripted or
documentary series and don't worry if if
you don't know what a philly d a is it's
just like a regular d.a but with onions
peppers and provolone toasted on a
hoagie roll
d.a.licious
distinguished actor murray bartlett is
here tonight oh
look at him good looking
he's nominated of course for playing the
resort manager on hbos the white lotus
murray i mean
it's an incredible performance but i do
have one quick question um the scene
where you pooped in the suitcase
was that improvised
because i mean you got kind of got to
get it on the first take am i
a long time between setups
and uh how'd you leave it with the prop
guy you guys still cool or no
yeah that's okay and here's a fun fact
uh did you know that murray bartlett is
also how you say merry christmas in
gaelic i did not know that that's very
festive murray barlett murdy bartlett to
you and and a hannah ein binder to all
how nice
it's very nice
michael grey eyes
is making history
he's making history with two nominations
tonight one for best male performance in
tv
and one for best male lead in film
now
i have not seen somebody dominate two
different mediums like this since megan
and i had sex with those two fortune
tellers
they told us we were gonna fuck them
and by god they were right
it was in the cards
you know what else i was just thinking
one of the nice things about this show
being right here at the beach is that if
you don't win you can just walk straight
into the ocean it's right there
just kill yourself so convenient
but um no wait am i wait a minute you
know what women winning is for losers
okay
winning is for big budget hollywood
trash that's right
this is independent film god damn it the
independent spirit where the heroes get
their teeth kicked in by reality fuck
yeah
real artists are all about pain and loss
they're about sad harshly lit nudity
with one notable exception of course
simon rex i think we have a clip there's
no there's no clip oh damn it
all right
while we go call our marriage counselor
let's go ahead and get started with the
awards part of this award show